Це, звичайно, якесь схоже на самогубство.
Кричати всім "охрана, отмєна"...
Треба виключно грюкати по столу і тоді все буде добре.
Перший заступник міністра економічного розвитку і торгівлі Максим Нефьодов -
новий глава Державної митної служби України.
Вперше в історії України цю структуру очолить
людина з іміджем наполегливого реформатора.
Чи вистачить Нефьодову оптимізму
на роботі з українською митницею й митниками?
Дуже рада вас бачити. Доброго дня.
Ви сказали, що за 2,5 місяці реально перезапустити митницю.
А за який термін Ви беретесь продемонструвати реальні зміни на митниці?
Це залежить від того, що означає "реальні зміни на митниці".
Звичайно, повна реалізація плану, який я представляв перед конкурсною комісією
і який я сьогодні виклав в інтернет, напевно,
займе десь приблизно 2-2,5 роки,
тому що є речі, які вимагають змін до законодавства.
Є речі, які потребують укладання міжнародних договорів
і, нарешті, потрібно в деяких випадках банально будувати митну інфраструктуру:
лити бетон, будувати будівлі, ставити сканери, ваги, камери розпізнавання облич і так далі.
Але є досить багато речей, де швидкі зміни
можна буде побачити досить швидко.
Митниця, з одного боку, в усіх громадян України
вона асоціюється скоріше з проблемами, з корупцією, поборами, непрозорістю роботи.
Але, з іншого боку, це означає, що там є  доволі багато таких…
Є такий український вираз, що це такі фрукти,
які низько висять і які можна досить швидко реалізувати.
Відповідно до того, що ви виклали в Інтернет - ваша презентація…
Чи можете ви назвати три якісь конкретні і реалістичні пункти, які можна виконати швидко?
Зрозуміло, що треба будувати максимальну кількість електронних сервісів.
Вже дещо зроблено. Але хочеться, щоб вже була повністю електрона митниця
і, відповідно, і державний орган, і самі митні інспектори, які там працюють,
і громадяни, і бізнес, який з ними спілкується.
У 90% випадків не повинні були спілкуватися один з одним наочно,
якісь передавати один одному папірці.
Все було б в електронному вигляді і шляхом обміну реєстрів.
По-друге, хочеться змінити кадровий склад митниці.
Мова не йде лише про банальне звільнення
якихось умовних поганих людей і наймання якихось гарних людей,
а мова йде про комплексну організаційну кадрову реформу
починаючи з того, кого ми наймаємо, звідки ми наймаємо цих людей,
як ми їх адаптуємо, як ми їх вчимо,
яка в нас політика підготовки або навпаки звільнення,
що ми робимо з оплатою праці.
Тому що я абсолютно відверто можу сказати, що з базовою зарплатою митника в  6000 гривень
ми можемо тільки мріяти про те, що ми
якось з ринку  наберемо кращі кадри, які будуть
успішно протистояти спокусам заробити якісь мільйоні хабарі.
Третій блок – це, звичайно, митна інфраструктура,
тому що, коли на митниці є черги, коли там жахливі умови роботи
і немає реальної ситуації гарно надавати послуги,
то з одного боку це стимулює корупцію:
кожен в черзі хоче там щось заплатити , щоб пройти першим.
А по-друге, це, звичайно, демотивує самих працівників,
тому що зрозуміло, що будь-якій людині важко працювати в таких складних умовах.
І зрозуміло, що треба додавати технічні засоби контролю:
ті ж самі сканери, системи розпізнавання облич,
автоматичні ваги, автоматичне розпізнавання номерних знаків, тепловізори і так далі,
тому що є види  порушень, із якими дуже важко боротися організаційними методами.
Із ними треба боротися  технічними  засобами.
За різними даними, корупція (на митниці) з’їдає приблизно 5 мільярдів доларів держбюджету.
Якби ії не було, Україна мала б ці гроші.
Як Ви будете боротися з контрабандою  на сході та заході країни?
Чи є там якась різниця відповідно до регіонів?
У нас створена, з моєї точки зору,  абсолютно неоптимальна структура,
коли в нас є 26 регіональних митниць, які якимось чином, я не знаю, конкурують між собою.
Невідомо, чим вони конкурують -
якимись ставками неформальними за розмитнення для клієнтів, так би мовити.
З іншого боку, 247 стаття Митного  кодексу дозволяє
будь-який товар розмитнювати через будь-яку митницю.
Тобто знов-таки створена ситуація, коли треба знайти слабку ланку -
одну слабку зміну десь на будь-якій митниці, через яку можна розмитнити:
хоч би ви ввезли через Одесу , а потім повезли цей товар на Суми і домовляєтесь там.
Тому я не думаю, що тут є велика регіональна специфіка.
Я думаю, що тут стоїть питання справді системної роботи,
і коли ця робота системна, то ці методи будуть працювати і на Заході, й на Сході.
Ви хочете перевести митників на контрактну службу.
Ви уявляєте той спротив, який Ви отримуєте.
Не боїтеся налаштувати проти себе весь апарат митної служби України?
Я не думаю, що є спротив у тому, щоб організувати роботу ефективніше.
Насправді проблеми оновлення - вони якраз великим чином залежать
від закону про Державну службу, який дуже ускладнює процедуру найму і звільнення людей.
Тому мені здається, що певне спрощення або повне виведення митниці з-під цього закону
або якісь спрощення по процесу оновлення кадрів - вони дуже необхідні.
Звичайно, мені б хотілося, аби ця робота не сприймалася так,
як в нас інколи розглядається робота держорганів -
від студентства до пенсії на одному місці, -
а сприймалася як робота з конкретними, чіткими kpi (прим.авт: показники ефективності)
і з конкретними вимогами, і які  йдуть не тільки з палицею,
якою, як у нас часто уявляє суспільство, треба більше бити, звільняти і карати,
а з конкретним розумінням, що якщо ти виконуєш ці kpi , то
тоді тебе підвищують, у тебе зростає зарплата, ти отримуєш якісь бонуси,
ти можеш отримувати якісь програми пільгового кредитування житла,
якийсь інший соціальний пакет.
Звичайно, в такій комбінації , я абсолютно переконаний,
ми зможемо залучати з ринку професійних і ефективних людей.
На всіх прикордонних пунктах пропуску є камери, приміром, в аеропортах
є камери, які фіксують роботу цих пунктів пропуску.
Як Ви збираєтесь зробити прозорою роботу митниці? Щоб усі це бачили?
На жаль, вони є не всюди.
На жаль, вони не працюють так , як вони мали б працювати.
Насправді, наскільки мені відомо, ще років 10 тому
на митниці були поворотні камери на багатьох пунктах,
якими керували саме з централізованого центру моніторингу в Києві.
Кажуть, що в деяких бригадах промишляли контрабандою в деяких змінах.
Навіть були спеціальні люди, відповідальність яких була весь  час дивитися на камери.
Як тільки вона починала рухатися, то кричати всім: "Охрана, отмєна!"
І всі кидалися  по кущах.
Тому, якщо відкинути жарти, то, звичайно, треба покращувати інфраструктуру:
вішати камери, вішати сканери, розміщувати там інші засоби технологічного контролю.
І, звичайно, викладати максимально всю інформацію онлайн.
Я виступаю за повну прозорість і доступність знеособлених даних про переміщення товарів і далі,
коли ми можемо аналітичними методами шукати якісь відхилення в цих даних.
Чи думаєте Ви про те, що Вам потрібна цілодобова охорона?
Я точно не хотів би жити з цілодобовою охороною.
Я якраз не розумію цього питання стосовно там безпеки.
Небезпечно бути на фронті, небезпечно сидіти , як наші військові,
під кулями чи то обстрілами. А ця робота, яку ми робимо тут,
вона може бути неприємною. Звичайно, нікому не хочеться сваритися,
нікому не хочеться звільняти людей чи стикатися з корупціонерами.
Але це робота, яку треба робити.
Мені здається, що два найбільші блоки,
по яких у нас реформи дуже слабко посилися з часів Майдану -
це саме Служба фінансових розслідувань і фіскальний блок.
Саме  тому я і пішов на конкурс на митниці:
тому що вірю , що це макроекономічно важливо і тому, що я хочу
показати приклад того, що треба не просто скаржитися в Фейсбуці,
що хтось має зробити реформу за тебе, а йти і робити  їх самим.
Чому Ви взагалі подалися на голову митної служби?
В "Прозорро " було так погано?
Тому що я вважаю, що треба йти туди , де завдання найскладніші
і ефект від вирішення цих  завдань є найскладнішим.
Ми дуже багато чого зробили в закупівлях
і, звичайно, ця робота не закінчена і корупція в закупівлях,
м’яко кажучи, на 100% не викорінена
і ухвалена "дорожня карта "євроінтеграції теж там розрахована на два роки,
але цей процес точно запущений.
Я вірю в свою команду. Переконаний, що "Прозорро " і "Прозорро-продажі" будуть успішно працювати.
А я дуже хотів би показати приклад саме в реформі митниці,
бо вона у виборців, платників податків, в усіх громадян України
асоціюється з проблемами , з контрабандою і корупцією.
Мені дуже хотілось би змінити цей імідж,
хотілось би, аби ії теж наводили як приклад, як і "Прозорро",
як те, де Україна не тільки наслідує чужий досвід,
а реально є лідером змін у світі.
Я абсолютно переконаний, що ми можемо цього досягти.
За яких обставин Ви зрозумієте, що Вам нічого не вдалося, що митниця не стала прозорою?
Ви знаєте, точно не буду працювати з якимось заступниками чи керівниками митниць,
яких призначають мені по квотах, чи радять, чи рекомендують,
чи наказують узяти ту чи іншу людину.
Якщо  в мене не буде свободи прийняття рішень,
якщо в мене не буде свободи кадрових рішень,
якщо буду розуміти, що моя робота - це, власне,
тільки прикривати якісь оборудки, які йдуть піді мною,
я точно напишу заяву і звільнюся.
Квоти почнуться одразу після виборів. Ви готові?
Я не думаю, що вони почнуться.
І поки що ніхто - ні Адміністрація президента, ні Кабінет міністрів -
ніколи не казали мені, що, мовляв, знаєш, ти йди на конкурс,
але ти ж розумієш, що треба цю людину взяти, або оце не чіпати,
або тут на щось закривати очі.
Ось у такому режимі я точно працювати не можу
і мені здається, що там весь мій досвід і вся моя репутація,
яку я напрацював у Міністерстві економіки, - вона це підтверджує.
Чи потрібна Вам якась політична воля від нового президента, якась підтримка?
Як ви бачите свою роботу?
Знаєте, мені не подобається слово "політична воля",
тому що вона закладає якусь таку презумпцію,
що для того, аби провести складні організаційні зміни,
треба виключно грюкати кулаком по столу і тоді все буде добре.
А хіба керівники Nokia - в них не було політичної волі зробити свою компанію успішною?
Напевно, була. Але  ця компанія померла, а якісь інші компанії
за цей час виросли і, як Apple, стали найдорожчими у світі.
Тому дуже багато залежить не від, як інколи вважається,
що це тільки ось бажання…
Залежить від професіоналізму, залежить від наполегливості,
залежить від уміння  заряджати колектив, від навичок лідерства,
від здатності сформувати коаліцію зі стейкхолдерами, яким вигідні ці зміни.
Наприклад, очевидно, що реформи на митниці вигідні "білому бізнесу ",
вигідні українцям, які  будуть бачити більше наповнень у бюджет,
і іноземним партнерам, які позбавляться проблеми з українською контрабандою.
Звичайно, їх треба збирати і тиснути ці реформи. Ну а як інакше?
Чи достатньо Вам повноважень для усіх Ваших планів?
Дивіться: в самій митниці у керівника, звичайно,
є повноваження проводити зміни, хоча є, звичайно,
обмеження в першу чергу відповідно до згаданого закону "Про державну службу"
і тому я дуже буду активно виступати за те, аби вивести митницю
або хоча б послабити обмеження закону "Про державну службу",
аби можна було ефективніше проводити звільнення і прийняття  людей.
Але з точки зору співпраці з іншими органами, звичайно, це робота,
яка вимагає координації і з президентською вертикаллю, і вертикаллю Кабінету міністрів,
тому що не можна перемогти одному.
Одному можна тільки програти, а перемагає команда.
Що вам  більше за все  подобається в тому, що Ви виграли  цей конкурс?
Ви знаєте, я не можу сказати, що це мені все дуже подобається,
тому що це величезний виклик
і з піарної точки зору це якесь схоже на самогубство,
тому що навряд чи можна бути популярним митником чи митником-реформатором.
У будь-якому випадку це пов’язано  і зі сплатою людьми грошей.
І люди, зрозуміло, не люблять, не хочуть платити гроші,
особливо в нашій країні, де є очевидні приклади, як ці гроші крадуться,
як гроші неефективно розтринькуються.
Зрозуміло, в цій ситуації це болісно. І платити податки болісно,
платити мита -  болісно. Тому я не можу сказати, що я дуже радію,
але я точно відчуваю відповідальність перед країною за те,
аби не змарнувати це вікно можливостей.
Мені здається, що в нас не було раніше таких вікон можливостей
для  реформ у фіскальному блоці і я дуже хочу своїм прикладом показати,
що можна навести порядок навіть у найстрашніших,
найтемніших куточках українського державного апарату.
Чи гідно Вам за це заплатить держава?
Ви знаєте, якщо чесно, я ще навіть не знаю, тому що
зарплата в державних органах не складається з якоїсь конкретної цифри, яку тобі можуть назвати.
Зараз у мене уявлення, що ця зарплата майже така сама,
як зарплата першого заступника міністра економіки.
Минулого року я чистими на руки отримав
близько 60 000 гривень на місяць.
Тобто Ви думаєте, що приблизно за цю суму Ви можете робити реформи?
Мені незручно скаржитися, тому що в мене була довга і успішна кар’єра
в інвестиційному банку і я, напевно, можу собі працювати за гроші,
які, можливо, менше того, що я можу заробляти в приватному секторі.
До того ж я переконаний, що на 60 000 гривень у Києві точно можна  прожити.
У мене немає якихось там бажань купувати супербрендові речі чи їсти ікру ложками.
Перша митниця, яку Ви відвідаєте?
Перша митниця… Зрозуміло, що ми почнемо з Києва і, напевно,
Київської енергетичної і Київської регіональної,
а потім поїдемо по регіонах. Найбільші, і це очевидно, - це Одеса, Львів, Закарпаття, Чернівці, Волинь.
Усі зміни почнуться вже в липні?
Я думаю, що реальна імплементація змін реально може початися скоріше з жовтня.
Як я казав, перші 2-2,5 місяці треба тільки створювати цю митну службу.
І я , власне, буду керівником без повноважень, тому що
всі мої майбутні підлеглі ще працюють в іншій структурі  - ДПС.
Частина цих людей переводиться автоматично.
Частина людей, можливо, не буде переводитися автоматично і пройде через конкурси.
Там є купа цих бюрократичних кроків, які за цей час
треба максимально  швидко і ефективно вирішити.
Але це до жовтня, так?
Це до жовтня.
Дуже дякую за інтерв’ю.
Дякую.